Chinese President Xi Jinping and his
French counterpart Emmanuelle macro have
issued a joint statement reaffirming
their strong support for the Paris
climate Accord in Beijing President Ma
cross said cooperation between Europe
and China on reducing emissions could be
decisive it follows the Trump
administration's move to start the
formal process of withdrawing the u.s.
from the 2015 Accord but she and McCrone
have said the Accord is irreversible
[Music]
over the past two years in the fight
against climate change we have
consistently acted together with great
effectiveness and commitment I regret
the choices made by a few other
countries but I want to see them as
marginal choices when China the European
Union and Russia ratify the Paris
agreement and make a firm commitment the
isolated choice made by one or another
country won't change the course of the
world and for more with me I have in the
studio Tim Schoenberg he's from the W's
environment desk welcome Tim now we had
both the presidents from France and
China talk about the praticed climate
Accord being irreversible what does this
really mean well let me explain a bit
China is the largest emitter of co2
emissions worldwide relying on coal as
their prime energy source at the same
time China just agreed to to reduce
their or to from just from 2030 on from
then on not emitting more co2 so
furthermore China has just a status as a
developing country within the Paris
agreement
this means that their commitments are
even less binding than the commitments
of industrial countries so this
Agreement this this statement has to be
put in a context of the EU trying to
bind China more into the Paris agreement
for speeding up their targets
so Amano macro is on a au mission
regarding
climate change in this context here so
you is kind of trying to take the lead
and in climate policies so let's take a
listen to what the Chinese President Xi
Jinping had to say in the face of some
of the most major changes ever seen over
the last century China and France has
permanent members of the Security
Council and representatives of Eastern
and Western civilization's must assume
more responsibilities as two powerful
nations so we had Asians been talking
there Tim and he's talking about China
taking more responsibility but in
actually per capita terms China is not
the biggest polluter it is Australia and
us is one of the biggest polluters given
that how much of a gap will USS pulling
out of the climate Accord have well
definitely the withdrawal of the United
States out of states out of the Paris
agreement is a big political loss
definitely I'm just to give one example
back then when the agreement was signed
China and India just agreed in large
parts to make commitments because the
u.s. United States were also taking
action so now there is definitely a loss
a gap sorry but as we see this agreement
being announced as irreversible we see
that there are attempts and there is an
effort to keep this agreement alive and
coming to a question if the U and China
are able to to fill up the gap oh this
is a an agreement on the paper so far
they will no measurements follow so far
and also China as with the status as a
developing country within the Paris
agreement will not have to pay for the
global Global Climate Fund which the
u.s. did so they will not close this
financial gap for something now at
another level you have some 11,000
scientists coming up with proposals and
talking about the urgency of taking
action to avert climate disaster this
seems to be
brought a momentum growing in society on
dealing with this issue
well definitely we have seen protests
the last year's last month's afraid of a
future many civil society groups green
parties are strong on the polls at least
in in in Europe so also the the
Commissioner commissioners
president-elect over laFonda line
announced in her first speech we want to
push the the green topics the climate
topics further in the next year's so it
is definitely a momentum but okay what
is coming out we have to see that there
in December that we will have another
climate conference in Madrid and if they
will further stack steps being taken if
there yeah if there are more agreements
we have to wait for that but we also
have to be clear about one thing this
trip from Accra and the meeting with
with cheating ping okay they they had
this disagreement making the Paris
agreement irreversible while calling a
reversal but at the same time they also
contracted trade deals about for about
15 billion dollars so it was also about
that right we have to keep it in
perspective as you said Tim Shawn back
from DW environment desk thank you very
much for that thank you